[Musique]
la pente à bonjour mes amis je suis
content de vous voir je prépare un
numéro de coûts l'équilibré star et et
je vais gagner beaucoup d'argent vous
savez comment je vous le dis mais n'en
parlez pas je vais réunir tous les gens
de l'île je leur demanderai un frein à
chacun et je commencerai mon numéro
comme ceci
regardez mesdames et messieurs voici une
corde qui est tendue entre l'arbre qui
est là et le kiosque qui hélas trop ami
casimir va traverser comme un funambule
sur cette corde alors je tendrais bien
la corde au sol et je ferai ceci
alors évidemment tout le monde criera
mais enfin casimir tomates de nous tu as
triché
l'accord déposé au sol je leur dirai ah
oui mais je ne vous avais pas dit à quel
hauteur je la mettrais aaa elle est
révolue mais ce pan casimir casimir si
tu connais la nouvelle je suis bon on
n'est ce pas oui oui très bon prix tu
sais que monsieur du snav à un cousin en
amérique il et cow-boys dans un ranch tu
as vu le mans mon bon maquillage de
combat mais je n'avais pas remarqué tu
mets tu te rends compte que c'est
incroyable un vrai coup ça on america
c'est qu'il va venir françois regarde ma
perruque comme elle est belle
rien rien bon voilà je vais marcher sur
une corde tendue entre le kiosque est là
ou qu'il aura désigné à quelle hauteur
points alors qu'en l'adour de poser
toujours les questions bien mais mon
pauvre casimir le clown pic nicolas déjà
fait ici même ses numéros casimir tu
ferais mieux de te préparer afin
d'accueillir le cousin d'amérique de
monsieur villeneuve j'y viens je vais te
raconter mais bien venir nous fabriquons
c'est bon
vous avez entendu c'est incroyable il
suffit comme ceux du snarr bien vague
cousin d'amérique pour que moi leur
meilleur ami je ne compte plus
haut mais j'ai une idée vous allez voir
je vais revenir le personnage le plus
important de lille grâce à ma malle
magique je vais me transformer en
cousins d'amérique de casimir vous allez
voir
[Musique]
ans
oh excusez moi de vous déranger mais
pour être pourriez vous me dire où je
pourrais rencontrer mon cousin casimir
oui je viens spécialement d'amérique
pour voir et bien écoutez il ne va
sûrement pas tarder savez-vous monsieur
que vous avez un cousin formidable oh
oui il est drôle gentil intelligent
excusez moi mais vous n'avez peut-être
pas bien compris mais je suis son cousin
et je viens d'amérique spécialement pour
le voir nous avions très bien compris
vous êtes son cousin et vous venez
d'amérique très bien mais moi j'ai hâte
de vous présenter casimir vous serez
fiers d'avoir un tel cousin vous avez
remarqué comme en piste sur l'airé beau
oui
c'est un petit peu normal que vous ayez
un pistolet un chapeau de cowboy puisque
vous venez d'amérique alors si vous
aviez vu casimir tout à l'heure dans son
costume de clown il était extraordinaire
vraiment il était formidable il était en
train de répéter un numéro de clown
extraordinaire tenez je vais vous le
montrez cher monsieur aurait j'adore les
numéros de clown
monsieur les possibles d'amérique
aviez-vous salle ou
allô monsieur les cousines d'amérique y
avait exécuté une petite numéro très
périlleux je vous parie une phrase qui
marche sur une corde tendue bien raide
depuis le kiosque ici jusque le alpes là
bas marché conclu mme d'hôtel à
walla iv sénat attendait à eux attendez
je connais déjà ce numéro vous m'avez
pas dit à quel montant sera la corde
très bien dans vos mots c'est le cousine
d'amérique mais c'est trop tard vous
avez parié et moi y'a qui coûte mon
numéro
à voir
sans vous le monde est à bout yves et
aux
caisses fériés ou une petite bosse ou
voilà
un bon numéro oui très bien quoi jamais
vous voulez peut-être que je vous parle
de ma vie en amérique oui mais alors
attendez il faut que nous trouvions
casimir d'abord vous savez il ya des tas
de choses à vous raconter et vous verrez
que ces histoires sont irrésistibles à
julie tu sais ce qu'on va faire nous
allons chercher casimir tout autour du
jardin
bon j'ai compris mort mon cousin
d'amérique ne les intéresse pas ce qui
les intéresse c'est un émirat c'est à
dire moi et que je leur raconte des
histoires drôles que je les fasse rire
enfin ça tombe bien parce que de toute
façon c'est ce que je préfère un bon
grâce à ma petite malle magique
je vais pouvoir redevenir casimir a
instantanément
mais voilà françois ans julie je suis là
casimir casimir tu sais la nouvelle ton
cousin gabéric est là enfin il était là
mais où est il bien pu passer bien au
jeu j'avais vu il était très près c'est
là qu'il a vu repartir tout de suite un
petit jeu comme c'est dommage il avait
l'air si sympathique je pourrais
peut-être romeo costume de clown et vous
faire rire excuse-moi kazinian mais
vraiment j'ai autre chose à faire que
d'écouter des histoires drôles j'ai
beaucoup de travail et faire tu sais et
casimir françois un réseau ou si j'ai
beaucoup de travail elle aura tout à
l'heure
vous les avez entendus
ils disent des choses gentilles sur moi
que je suis le plus drôle et dès que je
suis là et bien c'est exactement comme
si je n'existais pas voilà
vous aussi vous connaissez des gens
comme ça oui des gens qui ne font pas
attention à vous ou qui vous font des
réflexions désagréables qui vous grande
mais il y a une chose que vous ne savez
pas c'est que quand vous n'êtes pas là
ils disent des patchs aux gentils sur
vous bah oui c'est la vie
[Musique]